james is with us in nashville
hi james welcome to the dave ramsey show
thank you dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
hey uh i have a father who's a longtime
believer in keeping the cash nest egg
unfortunately he's pretty elderly
elderly now and that
nest egg has grown north of 500k
so i'm wondering what do i do with
500k of 100 bills
when he passes he's 87 now
and you know it's legitimately earned
he's run a business his entire life he's
put back a little bit of money every
month
and never spent it and here i am in this
dilemma
yeah who do you bank with
uh i think with regions okay
good uh go into them and talk to them
about a private banker
and um go ahead and and set your bank up
on notice for this and ask them how to
process this cash best
and well in advance so let's go and
start talking about it now
uh the uh atf requires a report
i believe it's over ten thousand dollars
cash comes in uh it's reported on you
uh to keep drug dealers from running
money through banks okay
and um so a report goes out but to the
feds
but that's not the end of the world it
just shows that it's there
and um yeah you know i don't i do not
know what a bank will require to process
that much
cash i know what i would require i'd
require an armed guard leaving his house
uh and it would certainly be best if you
could talk him into
he's sitting on hundred dollar bills
wow yes james is your 500
yeah is he does he have all his mental
faculties still
uh well that's another issue but i mean
he's probably 90 percent
okay i mean for his age would he allow
you to open a bank account and begin to
put this in
oh heavens no okay okay and the only
reason i asked about the faculties too
is
this is what you know about you know the
500 000. i'm i i'm just seriously in the
whole backyard with a medal
in the backyard just i would ask him
just then talk and say dad you know
where else did you used to put money and
just so you're able to kind of have a
trail
uh you you might be surprised there
might be closer to 750
or something you know all totaled or
once once you find it all
um yeah it just becomes home
go ahead yeah going through his home
after he passes will certainly be
oh my yeah i'm guessing he probably has
hoarded other things
uh not so much he loves his cash and
that's about
all he cares about okay all right and
you know where that is
he's got a bunch of real estate and you
know some other
holdings and such but uh it's mainly
this catches
cash is my big concern because you're
i'm always worried about civil asset
forfeiture and you know something when
you're doing it
are you an only child james uh yes
okay okay that's good well i yeah
i hope he has a will and anything you
can do to i just worry about his
security
yeah um and so obviously it hasn't
affected him so far in 87 years
so he's okay i don't panic about it but
um would you get a safe dave
and at least try to get something in
there to lock it down
that wouldn't be a bad idea you know if
you can talk him into it yeah and
there's
he may already have done it yeah he may
have or who he's told about it so just
keeping him safe yeah that's the that's
the idea
is that um my goodness gracious but yeah
you're gonna have to somehow
uh usually a private banker uh
would help you uh within your branch and
regions as a reasonable bank they should
be able to provide that
and can uh help you process the cash i'm
sure there is
a reporting mechanism i'm positive that
they have to go through
but i don't know how much it changes
between ten thousand
and five hundred thousand either i don't
so
that's uh when i say uh at the beginning
of the show cash is king
that is not what i meant just just for
clarity
okay just for clarity i don't have 500
000
in cash stored in my house i can promise
you that
uh yeah that money needs to be working
for you
it's not just in the hammock and that's
that's that's what it's doing just
sitting there